hello everyone and welcome to a really
wonderful game that i did not have plans
on showing today uh but then all of a
sudden i did uh as i've seen this photo
on twitter i mean i've seen it many
times but um this time uh douglas
griffin posted it on twitter and uh
he he just said like you know it's it's
a wonderful photo always to remember it
and uh he gave some additional info
about the photo uh how it was um taken
in the 1960 in the olympiad it was the
first clash between bobby fischer and
mikhail tal
after tal became the world chess
champion after defeating mikhail
botvinik and i was thinking okay but
yeah certainly i've shown this game and
then i was really interested if i've
actually shown this game because i know
i've pretty much shown all of fisher and
tal's games but
then it turns out i didn't uh which is
odd i mean i might have shown it but i
have like 3 000 videos and i don't
always name them properly so maybe i
have shown it but i really don't
remember it so i decided to show it to
you and uh you know
once i started checking out the moves i
don't remember actually ever showing it
so it's the seventh encounter
between uh bobby fischer and mikhail tao
but it's the first encounter uh since uh
mikhail became the world chess champion
so it's a very special one and it's
always a special one for fisher
until a certain point because he never
defeated tal the first two games that
they played the one in 1958 in porto
roche and the 1959 in city
ended in a draw and then in the 1959
candidates tournament in bled belgrade
and zagreb uh bobby lost all four
classical games to tal
which is incredible i mean of course
stal was the stronger player but uh to
not even get a single draw that's um
pretty spectacular on on paul's part
especially and it really helped to win
the 1959 candidates tournament so now
this is game seven between the two of
them and another chance for bobby to
take uh take at least one win away from
the magician of riga especially now as
he is the world champion so this is a
tremendous opportunity for bobby he does
have the white pieces uh and
well let's dive straight into it and
then we are going to discuss uh a little
bit more so fischer has the white pieces
and he opens with e4
and already a surprise from tal on the
first move he opens with e6 this game is
regarded by some as one of the modern
chess brilliancies and you you will soon
understand why uh some commentators
throughout the past uh said that it was
full of mistakes and that it really
wasn't anything special especially since
it's a bobby fischer against the world
champion mikhail thal
but uh you know now we have the
assistance of our good friend the engine
and you know the engine always is always
right basically and
this game is quite the masterpiece so
tall says that he chose the french
defense because uh he already even
though he was a world champion he
respected fisher tremendously and uh
uh he and his team especially his second
and trainer alexander koblenz uh decided
that it would be it would be maybe too
dangerous to play something like the
sicilian or e5 going to the rue lopez
against bobby so maybe a nice french
defense as bobby wasn't i mean bobby was
always strong but maybe he was not as
strong in in weird positions that could
arise uh in the in the frame defense and
they also did some uh special work on
the winner variation as you'll see so of
course d4 we have d5 and knight to c3 we
have bishop to b4 the winner variation
is on the board uh e5 advancing the pawn
and now pawn to c5 striking against the
center we have a3 and now pretty much
bishop captures on c3 is an automatic
you guys had this position on the board
many many times but here talgo's bishop
to a5 uh so he says that back in 1954 in
the ninth game of the smithsonian
botwinning match um
it was played and also but winning did
some work on this in the match against
untica in amsterdam olympiad uh but it
uh was kind of decided that the the
bishop to a5 line wasn't all that
impressive and that black really has
nothing to hope for here uh but uh he
and his team did some work on it and it
seems that it is it is possible to get
uh some action with this bishop to a5
idea so it's very interesting to see uh
what the bishop has in store for this
because of course uh
fisher has uh a reply to everything when
it when it comes to openings uh so here
b4 uh pretty much the strongest move in
any position we have c captures on d4
and now queen the g4 going after the g7
pawn uh even though nowadays uh knights
the b5 is uh is much more common and
then
black has to move the bishop bishop to
c7 for example you win the bishop fair
and you defend your e5 pawn and this is
perfectly fine white will have a very
enjoyable game
but fischer went for queen to g4 he goes
after the g7 pawn and not knight to e7
now again it's uh it's a well-known fact
that you can give up these two pawns in
the french defense so first the b
captures on a5 d captures on c3 and now
queen captures on g7
uh rook to g8 and queen captures on h7
and now knight b to c6 tell just
continues development goes after the e5
pawn so knights to f3 fisher defends the
pawn and now queen to c7 putting more
pressure on the e5 pawn developing the
queen also tal wants to play bishop d7
and castle queen side uh and here bishop
to b5 up until this point uh two of them
have played uh
incredibly precise moves and this is
main theory even today in 2022 uh only
nowadays bishop to f4 is known as the
absolute strongest continuation and you
will see how this is missing from this
game if the bishop is on f4 uh then it's
it's a much different game but here
fisher went for bishop to b5 he develops
the bishop pins the knight and now the
ship to d7 we have castles king side by
fischer and castles queen side by tal so
yeah castles are of on opposite sides of
the board
of course this means that we are going
to have fireworks on the board and here
uh fisher played bishop to g5 uh as uh
it's very interesting that both fischer
and tal annotated this game in in their
book fischer in the my 60 memorable
games book and tal in the life and games
of mikhail tal
and
bishop to g5 is definitely not the way
to go
fisher says that he
achieved a fairly winning position very
early on but
he uh very unwisely permits style to uh
unleash uh well what uh unleashes best
and now before we go into what happens
after bishop to g5 uh what are some of
the options here now after the game
fischer recommends a bishop characters
in c6 but it's um uh it's definitely
worth exploring this uh fischer gives
the next line bishop captures in c6
queen captures on f7 and now pawn to d4
as best for black and of course this is
all uh confirmed by the engine queen
captures on e6 with check and here's
where fischer gives um
the best move to be bishop to d7 just
giving up the knight for example bishop
to d7 now queen captures an e7 rook
captures on g2 with check king captures
on g2 and now bishop to h3
where black will win the white queen
king captures on h3 queen captures on e7
and now bishop to g5
with a winning position for for white
and while this is correct it's not the
only way to play this and of course now
okay you can play queen to h7 checking
to g3 queen captures in c2 you create
the the two incredibly strong past pawns
but after the shock characters king
captures the knight captures on d4 uh
the rooks will prevent you from ever
queening that pawn and the white just
has enough
material to to actually win this game so
what uh fisher missed here and it's a
very very peculiar why this happens is
that he says that if king to b8 uh then
a knight to g5 and white's position is
just uh completely dominant that black
can resign this but it's not uh it
doesn't appear to be so after bishop to
a4 which is the strongest move
recommended by the engine uh there isn't
all that much that white can do to uh to
prove this point for example queen to f6
uh rook g to f8 you go after the queen
queen to g7 we can go rook to g8 uh
queen to f6 rook g to f8 and it doesn't
appear like there's all that much if you
allow bishop captures and c2 then the
pass pawns will be incredibly strong but
you just don't allow something like
knights to e6 or
it's a very rich position of course
there's much more to play for
but with precise play it's actually a
dead draw so
this would be possible another thing you
could consider here instead of bishop
captures on c6 the recommendation from
fischer's book is just rook to e1 you
just defend the e5 pawn and you are
happy with it with everything because
now the trick of knight captures an e5
with the idea that the bishop captures
knight captures uh isn't really all that
impressive uh because now after queen
captures on f7 white is definitely much
better for example knight the knight is
hanging here so let's say knight to c5
we defend the knight bishop to f4 and
already this queen does not have a lot
of squares especially as the knight is
now coming to e5 uh let's say queen d7
95 queen here now you can even trade
captures captures rook 8 to b1 and white
has an amazing position uh this would be
uh most likely winning especially if you
consider the two the two past pawns here
but okay after rook t1 of course you
don't have to go for the tricky knight
captures on e5 you could just play queen
captures on a5 and the game continues uh
very very complicated but it's
definitely possible to play it for both
sides rook to b1 let's say knight to f5
bishop to g5 where bishop comes to f6
and it's a really wild position
but okay fisher kind of hurried hurry
this bishop to g5 move and now tal
unleashes what uh what he does best
knight captures an e5
a dazzling array of fireworks as fisher
puts it
so here if you go bishop captures on d7
it's not a problem we're going to play
rook captures and the seven knight
captures on e5 queen captures on e5 the
bishop now hanging so you don't have
time to capture on f7 pawn to h4 and now
queen to f5 tal would be able to force a
queen trade let's say queen captures
knight captures and the game continues
with um
uh chances for both sides it's knight
against the bishop uh fischer does have
the doubled a pawn but uh you know with
perfect play it should be a draw but it
would be very very very interesting so
instead after knight captures an e5
fisher goes uh for uh
uh
just a whole lot of trades uh a capture
fest if you will knight captures on e5
bishop captures on b5 now attacking the
rook knight captures an f7 attacking the
rook on d8 tal captures the rook on f1
fisher captures the rook on d8 we have
rook captures and g5 and knight captures
an e6 with a beautiful fork here
attacking the rook and the queen and now
tal goes for rook captures on g2 and
here
okay
you have to give it up as the queen was
also attacked and now you you would
expect fisher to play
king captures on f1 but fisher plays
king to h1 because if you capture on f1
it's not as clear what is happening here
now you can play rook captures on h2 and
now uh
the white queen is hanging also and you
can't give this check due to the knight
the rook also covers h8 and if you go
for a queen trait here knight captures
the rook captures uh how how do you save
the knight yeah if you move the knight
and then rook to h1 check picks up the
rook on a1 this is just lost for fisher
so here he wouldn't be able to uh he
wouldn't be able to trade queens here he
would have to go for something else like
uh queen to f7 uh but then we continue
with queen to c for check and the game
continues but it's much much different
let's say rook to h8 uh and the the game
stays alive now you can't really go for
the knight here uh because if you
capture the knight then you just get
nicely checkmated queen to g for
checking f1 and rook h1 checkmate so uh
it's definitely a good idea uh for
fisher not to capture the bishop he
plays king to h1 and now tells queen is
just hanging he has to deal with this so
queen to e5 attacks fisher's queen and
now rook captures an f1 grabbing that
bishop with queen captures an e6 and
king captures on g2 grabbing the rook
and here tao played queen to g for check
and he was in this position on move 21
that the game ended in a draw as there
is nothing more to be done here fischer
is up material he has the rook against
the knight so of course tal will be
forced uh at uh uh uh you know pursue
pursue a draw by repetition let's say
king to h1 queen to f3 checking g1 and
now of course queen to g for which check
and we will have a draw by threefold
repetition
uh so really really exciting uh game uh
the game seven between the two of them
uh ends in the draw which is good for
fisher at least he stops the bleeding uh
as he did lost the the four previous
games he played the tally in the uh
blood belgrade and zagreb uh
candidates tournament so now a draw is
definitely comes in handy and um uh yeah
if you guys are interested in what
happens next their next game will be on
bled uh it will be played next year in
1961 and this is actually the first time
that fisher ever defeats style i've made
a video on it some five years ago so
maybe you got if you guys want to check
it out it's quite that the game features
a beautiful queen sacrifice um uh if you
if you can call it that uh if you think
it needs a remake there's also a nice
story about bobby fischer on a boat with
dimitri b eliza so maybe you guys if you
haven't heard it you might enjoy that as
well uh but yeah i am willing to do a
remake of it if you guys uh think that
it's necessary uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it uh
first board usa versus soviet union if
you guys are interested in the standings
of the olympia these are the standing
soviet union of course won the event as
they usually did uh followed by second
place united states uh yugoslavia in
third place hungary czechoslovakia
bulgaria argentina west germany is
germany netherlands romania and england
and those were the standings so yeah and
that's the game understandings hope you
guys enjoyed that let's check out this
photo one more time because it's really
really awesome i could really uh you
know it's it's very sad that i don't
have this frame somewhere in my house
but i just don't have a good a good
place in my house for uh to hang a photo
like this but i i will make room for it
uh next uh next photo i i publish will
be this photo frame somewhere in my
house i uh i'm certain of that
uh so yeah really i really hope you guys
enjoyed this i hope i didn't miss
anything uh really i was trying to give
you as much information about the game
as possible like i said it was covered
in both of their books and pretty much
everyone in the world annotated it so
uh i i was very surprised that i didn't
cover this game or maybe i did if i did
you know feel free to remind me in the
comments uh yeah it's it it's uh very
hard to keep track of all the videos uh
so yeah once again i really hope you
guys uh enjoyed it um i uh i would like
to thank simon scofield uh john
shirtless robert mandeville uh david
mcfarland and john austin for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon uh continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world tomorrow
the granchester in croatia takes off so
we will probably cover a few games from
that
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day